tonight members of the Valley community
joined the rest of the country in a call
for change shutting down the Las Vegas
Strip thank you for joining us at 6:00
I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm Denise Valdez
the death of George Floyd has sparked
outrage all across the country after
video surfaced of his death while in
police custody and now those protests
have landed right in the heart of the
Las Vegas Strip we are tracking this all
with team coverage tonight here at six
Sasha Loftus and Vanessa Murphy are in
the crowds with those protestors and we
start with Vanessa with how to separate
protests eventually became one movement
down Las Vegas Boulevard Vanessa yeah hi
we're in front of the Bellagio where you
can see Metro Police are lined up in the
middle of Las Vegas Boulevard you can
see some police officers are in riot
gear even further down the strip toward
MGM you can see just how many Metro
police vehicles are here now we got here
at about 4:30 it was a black lives
matter demonstration facing up against
Metro Police they were further down they
moved this way but you can see most of
the demonstrators have left most of them
have left you have some on the other
side of Las Vegas Boulevard here again
you have police in the middle traffic in
both ways has come to a halt again much
earlier tensions were higher the group
was much larger but again you still have
Metro police here I'll show you some of
the demonstrators walked down the strip
more toward Circus Circus again a much
smaller group on the other side and what
we heard from demonstrators they are
angry about George Floyd and his death
they are angry about police brutality
they want their voices heard they want
to speak out against racial profiling
they want to speak out against racism
again they want their message heard they
call this a peaceful protest it did
upset them to see the police in that
gear over there because again they say
they were peaceful there was yelling
tensions were high again but right now
it is much more calmed that it was but
you still have metro police here in the
of Las Vegas Boulevard with traffic shut
in both directions also the culinary
union completely separate they tell me
they do they do support black lives
matter but the culinary union is
actually doing a caravan around the area
they want safety for workers as they
return to the casinos they want PPE they
want testing they want their voices
heard they had to change course a
spokeswoman tells me they changed they
were circling this trip from the welcome
to Las Vegas sign to Tropicana and back
so they changed their route they say
they support these demonstrators who
were here earlier again a much smaller
group right now I'll send it to Sasha
Loftus what's the video of do we know
Vanessa good evening now we took a step
away from the protest the main protest
area we're still on Las Vegas Boulevard
but you can see just a different vantage
point all of the police officers all of
these Metro officers blocking off Las
Vegas Boulevard in each direction the
road is completely shut down now as you
mentioned tensions were a lot higher
earlier definitely we were out here
around two o'clock 2:30 all the way down
at Circus Circus this protest has really
been fluid it's gone from all the way
from the Bellagio down to Circus Circus
back all the way down towards New York
New York then turned and ended toward
the Bellagio we did see a lot of
protesters sitting down in the middle of
the street clashing with police verbally
in the middle of the street again on the
sidewalk as police were trying to get
them out of the road and onto the
sidewalk again you're looking at some
video right now of those high tensions
high during this protest you can see
back out here live that road completely
shut down it looks like Harmon is open
in between but there are a lot of
traffic delays in the area so make sure
you're aware of that if you are getting
ready to drive near Las Vegas Boulevard
again this protests been going on since
around 2:00 this afternoon I heard a
protesters say they go all night though
Vanessa mentioned earlier that they have
started to disperse will of course keep
you updated both on air and online for
the very latest on these developments
here with this black black lives matter
protest on Las Vegas Boulevard for now
reporting live sasha Loftus 8 news
now Vanessa and Sasha thank you for that
and of course we will continue to track
these protests keep an eye on them
through our newscast tonight as well as
online in our website at 8 News now.com